hello everyone and welcome to a very
special video where we will be showing
two games uh by the first women's world
champion vera manchik
the first game we'll be showing is uh
from the carlsbad tournament of 1929
between the former world champion jose
royal capoblanca
he lost the the title to alejan already
here and the second game we'll be
showing is against the future world
champion uh from the
uh 1931-32 tournament in hastings
you know the those tournaments always
started like in november december and
then they spanned over through january
so
yeah don't be weirded out when it says
like uh hastings tournament of
19 you know 31 to 32 and there she will
be playing against future world champion
max irve
so that being said uh let's check out
this game first and then we're gonna
check out the other one and also there
is an amazing photo
of all the participants of this
tournament so i would just like to share
that with you as well
so uh here is the photo of amazing
quality
it's not a problem locating vera
menchikus she's the only women in the
tournament
there and as it usually is you know most
of the
not most of the but some of the uh grand
masters were frowned upon
a woman entering such an elite
tournament because this was one of the
biggest tournaments of that era and if
you if you've been following my saga
know that you can uh
identify most of the players here uh
like uh you you can see a capablanca for
example in the mid
in the middle there's a aaron nimsovich
on the right sitting next to
akiba rubinstein um you can see
uh the tatakova also frank marshall
there
on the top uh a a lot of very very
strong players here max yooda also in
the in the middle a little bit to the
left
so uh quite the uh quite the the team
and uh some a very funny term was even
coined
uh here in this tournament and it was uh
named the vera manchik club now i'm not
gonna
uh you know uh throw any names at you
but i will put a link in the description
below if you want to check it out it's
the first thing you'll see
uh we'll take you to an article by
edward winter that fully explains the
meaning of the veramentric
club but basically it was a a term
used uh by you know male players to
uh kind of make fun of other male
players who who lost the vera manchin
but
there are quite a quite a few notable
names that joined the veramentry club
and the gentleman who coined the term
uh was actually the first person to
enter uh the the set club
uh so uh that being said we're gonna
discuss a little bit more about that but
now let's check out this game and of all
of the strong names in this tournament
the only big names that are actually
missing here
are world champion alexander alejan and
former world champion emmanuel asker but
as you might know or may not know uh
after alejan took the title away from
capoblanca
he avoided playing in any tournaments
that capablanco was playing in
uh but we're gonna get to that when we
will be covering the aliyah
saga so that being said let's check out
this game and then we're gonna check out
the other one uh first i thought maybe
i'll just show
two of her most notable games or
something like that but then i decided
uh well you know what what's the point
if we don't show uh
you know the the game for example that
she played against the great cuban jose
world cup of blanca so i decided
i decided to start with that one as her
style is very very aggressive she has a
unique attacking style so let's see
let's see how she does against
uh jose roll so here she opens with
d4 we have knight to f6 by capoblanca
knight to f3
we have b6 kappa going for the some sort
of a queen's indian setup uh we have g3
preparing to finca to the light square
bishop and bishop to b7 now
uh and here we have bishop to g2 we have
c5 now striking in the center
uh sort of uh in some sort of an indian
game this is known as the marionbot
system
uh striking on d4 here we have c4 by
vera
and now c captures on d4 and here a
temporary pawn sacrifice of course you
cannot capture because the bishop will
be hanging here so just
castles now the king nicely defends the
bishop and you can pick up the
the pawn on the next move and here we
have queen to c7 by capoblanca
interestingly this this exact same
position occurred also in 2019 in a game
between levan ahrin and maxime vashir
lagrav
uh that uh maxime won it was a saint
louis blitz uh tournament and
he won a very nice victory here but he
played e6
here in this game we have queen to c7 by
capoblanca and now vera just
grabs bagged upon so queen captures on
d4 we have knight to c6
developing and attacking and now queen
to f4
offering queen trade and if capablanca
accepts then she also
develops her bishop already to the uh to
the very nice f4 square and this
position has never been
reached again after after this game uh
we have e5
capablanca declines the queen trade and
the queen back to d2
and now e4 pushing back this knight we
have knight to g5 now with a double
attack on the e4 pawn
and here uh interestingly kappa blanca
doesn't go for bishop to b4 it seems
like a very natural developing move but
he instead he goes
knight to e5 he opens up this bishop's
um
defense to d4 pawn and now they're
unable to capture on e4
and here knight the c3 interestingly
here
uh this pawn is defended and this c4
pawn is attacked twice so what you might
do here you might defend it with
something like b3 and then a couple
blanket plays h6 kicks away your knight
and so on
but here queen to f4 is actually an
incredibly strong move because it puts a
lot of pressure on black's position
uh you cannot claim the pawn with the
knight because the queen is hanging and
you can't capture with the queen because
the knight is hanging here
and other than that the this pawn is
attacked three times now so on the next
move you're just going to capture that
pawn
so it's a very very uh uh well
complicated position but queen to f4
definitely
the move uh to play here however she
played knight to c3
and now capablanca just goes knight
captures on c4 he grabs the pawn attacks
the queen queen to d4
and now d5 uh the only good move for
black as it also
uh defends the knight with the e4 pawn
she goes b3 kicks away the knight but
first bishop to c5 and this is the only
or the only actual move for black that
allows black to keep the advantage so
bishop to c5
attacks the queen and now not moving the
queen but rather knight to b5 and now if
bishop captures queen uh then knight
captures queen also comes
with check so here capablanco just moves
the queen attacks the knight here
and now queen back to c3 moving back the
queen
and now we will have a trade a knight
for a night so queen captures knight
b captures knight on c4 and now queen
captures on c4 kappa blanco grabs the
pawn and now offers a queen trade but
now comes queen to e5
with check and here capablanca only has
one good move that
doesn't lose him the game and that is
king to f8 point being if you play
something else if you if you try and
you know hold it all together like
bishop to e7 uh then just bishop to a3
and that's
that's it there's nothing much more to
be done here if knight g8
helping out with the defense just bishop
captures and after knight captures you
can capture here so it's a
total annihilation if now you you castle
queen side rook 8 to c1
uh just wins the queen so not much to be
done there
but capoblanca of course after queen e5
czech plays the absolute best king to f8
and now comes bishop to f4 just nicely
continuing development
we have queen to a4 now capablanca says
all right i've grabbed some material now
i want to go back and
trade queens we have rook after d1
and now queen to e8 offering a queen
trade and vera of course declines queen
back to b2
we have h6 pushing the knight back and
now knight to h3
the knight will be very strong here as
it also helps out with
the defense of the f2 pawn so knight to
g4
not a problem the f2 pawn is already
nicely defended and now
rook ate the c1 a very sneaky move by
vera
if capoblanca is not careful for example
if you go something like this then she
immediately grabs the bishop here and
also grabs the other bishop on b7 and
now she's just better
so here capablanca goes bishop the c6
doesn't allow this trade and now comes
e3
uh but this was the the moment in the
game where she could have
uh gone for for a better idea rook
captures on c5 is uh still a viable plan
because after pawn captures you can now
play bishop to d6 check
king moves and now you grab this pawn as
well and now yes you've sacrificed the
exchange but you have the bishop pair
and you know you're still you're still
finding uh the
you know it's never easy fighting
against the bishop pair and another
thing
black still has to figure out how to
bring this rook into the game he's gonna
have to waste a few moves and maybe
maybe just maybe
white can take some advantage of this
black is better here
but maybe it wasn't uh you know maybe it
wasn't a bad idea
but okay after bishop to c6 she played
e3 but now capoblanca just goes king to
g8 he wants to play king h7 and shift
his
rook into the game uh we have queen to
e2
attacking the knight but now just f5
defending that knight
we have f3 trying to push away the
knight knights to f6
and now g4 even uh but here copper
blanket just captures and if
on f3 we have bishop captures on f3 and
now
f captures on g4 with a double attack on
the knight and the bishop so you have to
capture
but now queen to g6 pinning the attacked
piece the bishop is now attacked by the
knight and by the queen
here vera defends it with knight to f2
but now capablanca just pushes h5 and it
was
in this position that vera manchik
resigned to the game uh as
there is nothing more to be done here
you will just suffer
uh you know severe material loss here
once capablanca starts capturing here
this will open up the rook
uh the bishops are excellently placed
there there is no point in continuing
this game
so uh this is a game i wanted to show
you just that uh to give you an idea of
how she
fares against uh you know capablanca who
is who is basically the
the strongest player in the world is
some claim even even though alien took
the world chess championship title away
from him that capoblanca still was
considered the the absolute strongest in
the world
and these are the standings of the this
tournament um
just to show you uh so you can see uh
capablanca did not
win the tournament capablanca uh got 14
and a half
out of 21 so that's 10 victories two
losses and nine draws but the tournament
was won
by aaron nimsovich who had the the
tournament of his life
and he won the tournament with 15 out of
21. 10 wins only one loss
uh and 10 draws and as you can see vera
menchik
uh not do not all that great she she
finished in last place with three out of
21
but still she got two wins uh 17 losses
and
two draws so uh definitely not uh
uh not a pushover yeah because even if
she wasn't in the tournament someone
else
would have been last so uh they said
someone someone even said you you can
read this in the link i provided in the
description below
uh someone said that if vera grabs even
three points in the tournament
that he will dress up as a ballerina uh
for
for for the next tournament and uh well
as she did win uh three points uh
who knows if this ever happened i
haven't i've never seen i've never heard
such a story
but maybe maybe it did happen or maybe
you know they were just too ashamed to
admit they were wrong that she can
actually win points against the the
strongest the male players in the world
so this is how she fared against uh the
great cuban but now i would like to
present you a game she played uh
three years after this so in the in the
hastings tournament
against the none other than the future
world champion max urba
let me just switch couple blanca with
over here
give me one two three seconds maybe
his name isn't actually max irve it's uh
it's a dutch name that i can't pronounce
so i'm not going to even try
but some of you i will put it here so
you know
most of you or rather all of you can can
see it
it's uh something something in the like
magellan although i have no idea how
that is pronounced so i'm just gonna
stick to max and there we go
let me just save that
all right so
now capablanca turns into max uva and we
go
into a very very nice game that was
played in the hastings tournament 1931
1932 as it you know goes over the new
year
and yeah in the previous game that we've
shown she faced
the former world champion but now she
will face the future world champion this
was played in 1931 1932
and as you know max ulve uh grabbed the
title from alexander alejan in 1935 he
held on to it for a year and then
alejandro won it back
but let's see this one and uh now you
will see
how much uh she improved in in this very
very short time
so vera uh with the white pieces goes
for d4
uh we have d5 by over we have c4 and now
c6 going for the slav defense uh knight
to f3
knight to f6 and now knight to c3
so just a normal uh three nights
variation of the slav
d captures on c4 and now a4 she stops
black's further expansion with b5
we have bishop to f5 and now e3 and this
is
the absolute top theory that's even
being played today in 2021
so here knights to a6 developing the
knight and now
bishop captures on c4 we have knight to
b4
uh and now comes castles uh we have e6
preparing to develop the dark square
bishop and now
knights to e5 and this position still
there are games in the database from
2020 that have this exact same position
on the board
from top tier tournaments we have bishop
to d6 continuing development
and now she plays queen e2 she doesn't
want to allow for example captures
captures and
the the trade of queens she wants to
keep queens on the board
uh we have c5 by eva striking in the
center and
now comes bishop to b5 with check the
king now has to defend
and here over makes the first big
mistake of the game
uh he has to play king to f8 here but
rather he plays king to a7
and it looks like you know just a normal
move uh he didn't want to play king to
f8 because then it's problematic to
bring this rook into the game so he
wanted to play king to e7
and then bring the rook into the game
and just play king of f8 you've castle
artificially all is well
but now i'm sure you will find it
so feel free to pause the video and win
this game for vera
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
you can actually win a piece here and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's
e4 and e4 is such a such a wonderful
move the bishop here is under attack and
you have to move it you cannot go here
it's guarded by the knight and by the
queen so you have to go back
bishop to g6 but now now there's a
problem because now
knight captures on g6 comes with check
h captures and now e5 so winning uh
winning a piece here
uh we have c captures on d4 now
attacking white's knight here
and uh it would be very dangerous uh i'm
sure this wasn't even a blunder by hugo
i'm sure that
this was some sort of a plan on how to
go for some sort of a mating attack for
example if captures captures then black
already has some very very strong
threats here the knight can
also join joining the attack you can
double rooks here maybe rook h6 rook
other comes to h8
maybe it would be very hard for white to
defend this however
vera goes for the absolute strongest
rook to d1
not going for material right away and
saying you cannot capture here because
if you capture on c3
then i play rook captures on d6 attack
your queen and after the queen moves i
just capture here and attack your knight
and what do you play here
uh there's not a good move for black
here uh just to give you an example
if you play queen captures on c3 you go
after the rook here
it's game over e captures on f6 with
check king captures on d6
and now bishop to f4 with check and
that's it
uh for example e5 rook to d1 with check
king to e6 and now queen to g4 with
check
king captures and bishop g5 will be
checkmate
so those are the dangers that lurk in
the position after rook to d1
so uv a very very strong player himself
plays
bishop back to c7 and only now e
captures on f6 with check we have g
captures on f6
and now comes g3 as uh this pawn here is
being under attack
so g3 defending and now a6 pushing
vera's bishop back we have bishop to
e3 disregarding this threat on b5
now going after the d4 pawn and now the
thing is if the bishop is captured
the problem is bishop captures on d4 and
there's nothing for you to do bishop c5
check you lose the queen so you'd have
to play something like bishop d6 the
to guard against this but now queen f3
you go after the f6 pawn
and after you defend this let's say e5
bishop back to e3 now again you have to
worry about the rook here
and once you unpin now you can even go
for rook captures and d6 these are the
dangers in the position if king captures
queen captures on f6 with
check king to c7 and now you just go in
for the kill knight captures with
check king b8 queen captures with check
and that's gonna end in checkmate so
uh those are the uh just some of the
ideas if you decide to capture the
bishop so instead
bishop the b6 by uh not going for
material
uh and now bishop back to c4 finally
vera moves the bishop we have king to f8
and now comes knight the e4 finally not
bringing the knight into the attack
uh this still cannot be captured the
queen is still on
on the 8th so king to g7 and now comes
rook 8 to c1 and all of her pieces are
now fully developed whereas uh black
still has to
develop the rook and figure out what uh
uh what's the plan here so here
rook the h5 a very nice way of uh
bringing the rook into the attack we
have bishop to f4
now with ideas of maybe some uh the
knight can come to d6 also the bishop
can come to d6 put pressure on this
knight so e5
pushing the bishop back but now g4 that
was
always the plan just shifting the bishop
over to g3
the rock has to move so rook back to h8
and now
bishop back to g3 uh we have queen to e7
uva develops the queen connects the
rooks and now
knight to d2 uh the queen is now coming
to e4 and the knight is coming to f3
so if you look at the position now vera
is still up a piece that you want
but uh uva has a massive center here and
he's gonna
start pushing those pawns as soon as he
consolidates a little bit
so rook h back to e8 and now queen to e4
they're keeping an eye on this this pawn
push uh and
here comes queen to d7 now queen to c6
and ewtha wants to trade queens and even
though he's a piece down
he will try to make use of those extra
pawns so here
knight to f3 and queen to c6 now
offering a queen trade vera accepts this
with captures captures and now
bishop to d5 attacking the uh the knight
also preparing bishop e4
again to help out with uh the defense
against this pawn push
so rook ate the c8 and now bishop back
to e4 guarding against f5 we have rook
to c7
uber now prepares to double up rooks on
the c file and now
knights the e1 uh we rook eat the c8
doubling rooks here and now knight to
the knight to d3 she's ready for an
exchange along the c
file knight to e7 this is how uber plans
to
make some uh you know progress in the
position
and she just happily trades here with
captures captures and
king f1 beginning to improve the
position of the king
rook the c4 going after the a4 pawn and
now
bishop captures on b7 rook captures on
a4 and now comes
rook to c1 uh we have g5
clearing the g5 g6 square for the knight
then you can bring the knight into the
game
we have f3 and now rook to eight you're
going after the pawn here
so bishop to e1 now offering a pawn
uh but uh what are you gonna do if uh
for the moment the
the pawn cannot be captured as the
knight is here uh but
the knight cannot remain there forever
so here we have a5
uh starting to push that past pawn uh
not a pass pawn yet but
uh at some point uh it might be so here
bishop to d2 and this bishop to d2 is a
waiting move
vera is waiting for uh for uh to start
pushing this pawn because if you
continue pushing it then bishop b4 is
very dangerous you attack the knight
and that's it the knight cannot the
knight cannot move you
you have to play something and give up
the knight because if you move the
knight then comes
bishop here and then the rook is
captured there's no move here
that you can make for black so uh not
the greatest of position so after it's
bishop to d2 move we have
f5 here now this is a very cool trick by
uve
g captures on f5 and now a4 so
this is how he plans to trick vera now
if vera goes for the same line that
we've shown
uh bishop to b4 attacking the knight
he's just going to play
knight captures on f5 and after bishop
here attacking the rook
now he was planning knights the e3 check
picking up the light square bishop so
this is how he was
planning to go about it but the vera
just says nope i'm
i can see what you're planning just king
to e1 that
check at the end of the variation will
not be happening and now
uh he for the lack of a better move just
trades a trade spawn for pawn
so here vera doesn't even want to trade
b4
now she has a pass the b4 upon herself
and this rook has no squares
all of these squares are covered so the
rook pretty much stuck there we have
king f6
now comes bishop to a6 preparing to trap
the rook
uh g for now and just bishop to c4
there's no reason why
the rook shouldn't be captured right
away and now you have to give it up rook
captures and d2 was played
king captures on d2 and now g captures
an f3
uh we have knight to c5 uh not
much for uh for black to do here the
thread is knight here check we'll pick
up the bishop on b6 so here just king
captures on f5
and now bishop captures an f7 uh we have
bishop back to d8
and now bishop to e6 with check king f6
and now
bishop back to g4 going after this pawn
so black has
four pass pawns here but uh they are not
very well supported so knight to d5
and now bishop captures an f3 we have
knight captures on b4 and now
bishop to e4 with bishop to e7 putting
pressure on the knight here
knight the d3 now offering a trade of
knights and of course uh black
doesn't want to want to trade here
because well yeah he's just
still down a piece so knight to a2 and
now rook to c6 with check we have king
g5
and rook the g6 check now king to h4
and now knight captures on e5 just
grabbing those pawns
knights the c3 now hoping to get this
pass pawn all the way but here vera just
played king to d3
and it was in this position that future
world champion max uva resigned to the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here
but we will not leave the position here
i'm going to show you why he resigned
because
after the well after the game continues
for example a2
yes you are winning you are bringing a
queen into the game
the problem is you're also getting
checkmated bishop to f3
and now there's nothing more to be done
if a1 queen then just uh
rook the g4 with check and that's it if
you go up the board
rogue g won a discovered check wins wins
the queen and then black is just uh you
know
without hope and if you go down the
board king to h3
then then comes bishop to g to check the
rook defense bishop knight defends rook
uh only move king captures on h2 and now
knight to f3 is checkmate
so this is why uber resigned he did not
wanna uh
face uh this uh this position on the
board and he himself became member
uh uh an honored member of the vera
manchuk club
and uh sir george thomas uh who lost to
her twice uh
they even joked that uh he is not only a
member of the vera mentioned club that
he is also
uh as a secretary of the club as you
know he's so
a frequent member there uh but yeah uh
also very interesting
uh to know uh so yeah they they did have
a laugh they did a joke around but you
know everyone was
secretly very scared of of becoming a
member of the vera magic club
so vera like i said was the first
women's world champion
uh by winning it in 1927 and she
successfully defended her title
six times in every other championship
held during her
lifetime losing only one game while
winning 78 and the drawing four games so
she was
the you know the absolute monster no one
could even uh
uh come close to her skill uh so yeah
those are the games hope you guys
enjoyed that against uh jose royal
capoblanca and the max yuva uh former
and future world champion
uh so i hope you guys really hope you
guys enjoyed that and i
i don't think we've covered a game by
vera so far i think we covered one game
so far but that was like four
years ago and uh yeah for the end of the
video let's uh enjoy this uh
not that obviously let's enjoy this uh
one more time
as you know uh so many so many great
faces here and if anyone uh
wants to give it a shot try to name all
of the players here and i will pin your
comment for everyone else to see and
admire your
your vast knowledge uh so
uh that's the game or rather those are
the games hope you guys enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank mr hoodie guy
uh chloe hall
another mr hoodie guy vishnu ns and
professor eugene victor flynn for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing uh the
uh coverage of the morphe saga checking
up on your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day
and do read up a little bit more in the
link in the description below
see you soon